all right so I got tricked by a trumpist
and I'm going to tell you about it and
um I think this is really instructive
and and informative so last week when we
were taking live calls on the Friday
show I got a call from a guy who says I
used to be a moderator for the Donald
the Donald that's the underscore Donald
was one of the most toxic pro-trump
subreddits on the website Reddit
um until it got banned the entire thing
was banned for just constant
disinformation and violating you know
all sorts of terms of service of Reddit
and uh during that call this trumpist
moderator said to me hey David you know
uh Now They are promoting the use of
misoprostol for abortions and it's just
as unproven as Ivermectin so isn't there
a double standard on social media and
here's exactly what he said and how I
responded to it let's go next to uh
let's go to Rich from Illinois Rich
welcome
hi David hello
um so that was the top mod of the Donald
on Reddit for years until just before it
was banned and with Elon buying Twitter
do you think that there will be a
general shift in policy for the uh the
tech places
um towards allowing things
like medical misinformation such as
Ivermectin and what vices motherboard
did yesterday with uh tweeting out the
misoprostol for abortion pills
I what I didn't see the bike what's the
vice thing tell me about that yeah so
they uh tweeted out from their
motherboard account that misoprostol
which is a horse medicine uh to treat
ulcers for horses can be used for
abortion pills oh I see that now yeah uh
okay so let's go step by step first I uh
I actually discussed this with Coleman
Hughes in an already recorded but not
yet released podcast episode with him I
actually don't think that Elon Musk
taking over Twitter if it happens
remember it's still not been approved
and I think it may not be but we'll wait
and see I don't think it's gonna do
anything mind-blowing on on Twitter per
se I think maybe some people will be
unbanned maybe not I don't know that he
is widely going to be involved in
content moderation so I'm kind of res
I'm not making any big judgments about
what's going to change on Twitter let's
first wait and see if the the buyout
actually happens and then we'll kind of
think about that part
um in terms of uh I mean listen I don't
know much about this misoprostol thing
but I I also don't know whether this is
an approved off-label use or not I don't
know anything about it but let me just
say right now all of this stuff should
be should be subject to the same
scrutiny whether it's being promoted by
left or right I think it all should be
subjected to the exact same terms of
service
okay that's good so I responded in
principle because I didn't know anything
about misoprostol I just hadn't heard it
I hadn't heard about it up until this
point and uh I said well if if the
circumstances are the same if
misoprostol is really to abortion what
uh Ivermectin is to covid
if they really are equivalent then it
should be handled the Same by social
media but it turns out that the trumpist
either lied to me or just was ignorant
himself because a bunch of doctors and
pharmacists emailed me and said David
you got tricked there is no similarity
between Ivermectin and misoprostol let's
look at some of these emails that I got
here's the first one I'm a medical
doctor Family Medicine as part of my job
I delivered babies for seven years I
just watched your interview with the ex
the Donald moderator
misoprostol more commonly called cytotec
in the U.S is an extremely commonly used
drugs in humans we use it to help induce
labor and can be used to cause an
abortion in the first trimester by
dilating the cervix and allowing the
product of conception to fall out I've
never performed an abortion so my
knowledge base on that is limited but
I've used cytotec to induce labor
hundreds of times to compare it to
Ivermectin is a mistake that's one
medical doctor another medical doctor
wrote in hi David huge fan listening to
the Friday Collins wanted to share that
misoprostol is indeed approved for human
use has the U.S brand named cyratec so
it's either cytotec or cyrotech there's
the disagreement on that but clearly
we're talking about the same medication
used by OB gyns for inducing miscarriage
slash abortion used to help women pass a
partial miscarriage used to induce labor
during the third trimester and also used
for prevention of nsaid-induced
ulcers his idea that it's a horse
medicine and not a human one is not true
it is used for both as is Ivermectin I
am an internal medicine physician so I
don't personally use it often an
obstetrician could provide more details
about when and how they use it I have
prescribed it to patients for ulcer
prevention that's Dr Isaac and then a
pharmacist wrote in who said you
recently took a call from a former the
Donald moderator Who mischaracterizes
misoprostol as a horse medicine to treat
ulcer for horses and not approved for
humans in an attempt to liken its
promotion to that of ivermectin for the
treatment of covid misoprostol is both
FDA approved for human use and indicated
as an abortion drug and has been proven
to be both safe and efficacious for this
indication the same can't be said for
Ivermectin and the treatment of covid
while I can't in good Consciousness
recommend or promote people taking a
prescription strength drug absent
supervision of a licensed Medical
Professional this equivalency is
patently false and misleading that's
Kyle the pharmacist so listen you
tricked me the Donald moderator maybe I
mean the maybe the guy knew that it was
a false equivalency
but
um uh you know the the important things
here is okay Ivermectin
sometimes used in horses sometimes used
in humans
misoprostol sometimes used in animals
sometimes used in humans Ivermectin not
okay to use for covid based on
randomized controlled trials misoprostol
regularly used as an abortion drug in
humans so not the same thing and uh this
is why you know
I said and this is why we we should
never go beyond what we know and so when
the Ivermectin people started with the
Ivermectin stuff it wouldn't have been
right for me to say it doesn't work for
covid it will never be shown to work for
covid
maybe it does and it hasn't been shown
yet maybe someday it will be shown to
work for covid what I knew at the time
was we don't have any good science right
now that says Ivermectin works for coven
and so let's be thoughtful when we make
claim that it's actually not going
further than what we know at the time on
the other hand when it comes to
something like misoprostol which I knew
nothing about I responded and said I
don't know a thing about that in
particular if the circumstances are the
same as Ivermectin then it should be
handled in the same way by social media
companies it turned out later it is not
at all the same thing so hopefully an
instructive moment for all of us